what's going on guys rogue one hits
theaters on December 16th so we've set
out with the simple task of determining
the greatest Star Wars character of all
time Wow
a monumental task lies ahead but we've
got an epic panel of Sith and Jedi Minds
to help us determine the greatest
character in the Star Wars galaxy ah
let's meet our panel
he's an old friend of the show you know
from belated media and he's made some
excellent Star Wars related videos
welcome back Michael Barrett thank you
for having me this man is an old pal of
the show ah you know him you love them
and you can see them on colliders Jedi
Council
welcome back Kristian harloff our old
pal you know them as the pit boss you
can see them on Collider and you can
hear them on the Star Wars related
podcast force center and nap sock we've
broken the Star Wars universe down into
nine specific divisions of characters
and we're going to work our way through
each division until we come down to two
final Star Wars characters and then we
will determine the one Star Wars
character to reign supreme and name them
the best Star Wars character of all time
all right our first division we're going
to determine a winner of the nerf herder
slash Friends of solo division you're
going to choose from
Chewbacca Lando Calrissian Maz Kanata
and burrito Michael let's start with you
pick one of those four he's the
smoothest dude in the galaxy at Lando
Calrissian hello what have we here oh
that's one for Lando Christian you don't
go against the family dog it's Chewbacca
Chewbacca one one can nap sock oh you're
breaking my heart already but I'm gonna
go with Lando as well because that is a
character that helped expand the
universe in Empire Strikes Back whoa
that is a huge upset how damn yo
Calrissian how dare you people they
won't even cast Lando in other movies if
whether they finally got him in a
younger version in Han Solo we haven't
seen yet
Chewbacca has been the glue Wow already
an upset an epic character falling in
the first round
okay so Lando moves on next the Sith
division Emperor Palpatine Darth Maul
Count Dooku and General Grievous let's
start down on this end with Ken APSA you
know there's some interesting characters
or dukkha was more layered than people
give him credit for but good good
Emperor Palpatine
is the man that's one for Palpatine
let's go right around to michael barratt
'hey i'm split between Palpatine and
Maul Palpatine has a long-standing
history of evil and yeah he's got an
exceptional voice I however I'm going to
go with Maul purely based on potential
and if we can expand just a little bit
out into the Clone Wars like he's a fun
character that gets a little bit more to
do in their malls great and Maul did
have a great archive of Clone Wars and
in rebels but Palpatine kicked his face
him like a they fought in the Clone Wars
he beat him and what it is about
Palpatine he was the Phantom Menace he
was the one that built all this he built
the Empire and they're still following
his design in the force awakens it's
Palpatine the force is strong in
Palpatine moving on next up the Jedi
Master division obi-wan Kenobi Yoda mace
Windu qui-gon jinn let's start with
Kristian harloff this is gonna be tough
I'm gonna go obi-wan and I'll tell you
why because obi-wan basically throughout
had to protect Luke Skywalker who's
without obi wan's protection in the
beginning yeah Yoda train them but
obi-wan kept them alive for all those
years so I just it's tough but I'm just
gonna go be one can't go wrong there
Michael I'm in the same camp on your
logic that said Liam Neeson as qui-gon
jinn I do love a lot I just want to put
that one out but your table you're
taking I'm taking obi-wan I'm taking
over one for sure Ken who would you have
chosen just for sake it would have been
a clean sweep with obi-wan but Yoda
definitely carry some weight oh yeah got
to show some love for Yoda Yoda did so
much I mean look Yoda trained obi-wan
Yoda was the one who got obi-wan out
revenge the sets was basically telling
him look here's what I found I was able
to contact your old master Yoda is the
Guru of it all but it's just something
overall the arcing story oh yeah
obi-wan is moving on
failed I have let's move on to the
rebellion division competing here are
wedge antilles Admiral Ackbar Mon Mothma
Bail Organa and Padme Amidala
where's Porkins much like the Battle of
Yavin Porkins didn't make it for some
out for Porkins there you go let's start
with Ken you know what I'm gonna do wild
card pick Padme Amidala whoa that is one
for Padme Christian this particular
category has to play in to the other
cannons of the Clone Wars the books and
because of that I am gonna go wedge
antilles
I think that you Padme is also an
argument for that because of everything
she did in the Clone Wars Expanded
Patton a lot absolutely but with wedge
he is a character that was really one of
the faces an unsung hero really of the
rebellion he should be respected a lot
more well you just threw a wedge in
Padme his plans Michael Barrett II I'm
gonna throw a further wedge cuz I'm
going Mon Mothma oh yeah she's a huge
Orchestrator of all the events on the
trench run and then we're going to be
seeing more of her in rogue one I'm
excited to be seeing that and I think
there's a lot to her character and I
don't know she fascinates me okay well
Admiral Ackbar will be trapped in the
first round pitch a drama but we have a
three-way tie to see who will move on
wedge antilles mon mothma Padme Amidala
ken is there is there any swaying you
Michael
Christian is there any flexibility yeah
I'm gonna change my pic oh really I'm
gonna give it to a win here and I'm
gonna go with Mon Mothma
I think that Mon Mothma especially even
I know that the movie hasn't come out
yet but you look at just the trailers it
looks like she's gonna be bringing in
jyn erso to do a lot of stuff so she's
gonna have a bigger role and was in a
deleted scene Revenge of Sith forming
the rebellion its Mon Mothma you're
right alright there we go
Mon Mothma moving on let's travel to the
force awakens division your choices are
Rey Poe Dameron Finn and kylo Ren let's
start with Michael
I'm gonna go Finn on this one he is
driven and looking to make some serious
shake ups in the galaxy gotcha
that's one vote for Finn let's go back
around to Ken to me Rey is one of the
most important Star Wars figures she is
a very powerful character and I know
that sometimes Roku
the wrong way but it was important to
have that character take that journey
and I love the moment where she goes
from I thought Luke Skywalker was a myth
too she's handing the lightsaber to Luke
at the end it gets me emotional every
time it's my favorite ending in Star
Wars she's one of my favorite characters
nicely put okay so we have one for Ray
one for Finn
it's the easiest one so far for me and
it's right you just automatically
connect to her what is does she have
parallels to Luke in one way or another
yes whether I should really relate it to
him we'll find that out but it's that
hero's journey that she's on and we're
on it with her so it's right there's so
much to look forward to with Rey and she
is moving on right here in our bracket
what you do i bypassed the compressor
moving on to the monster division
Sarlacc rank or a slug wampa Kristian
harloff when the first time you saw the
rancor in Return of the Jedi it's
horrifying it really is that Luke's got
to fight it with a rock I mean this is
all these things
it's the Wrangell that's great stuff
okay Michael barity I'm going whomp on
this one
the wampas great not only in the fact
that it is monstrous but it also shows
how far Luke has come as a Jedi because
this is the very first time that he
pulls the lightsaber with the force good
argument that's one for the Wampus so
we're tied up rancor wampa each have one
can nap suck I have to go back to when I
was 7 sitting in the theater watching
returned the Jedi the rancor came on I
did this Oh
rank or for scaring a young kidnap Zach
the rancor moves on
some have called this collection of
gentlemen the most wretched hive of scum
and villainy in the galaxy who's been
saying [ __ ] of my mother but right now
we're going to determine the winner of
the scum and villainy division Jabba the
Hutt Boba Fett Sebulba grand moff tarkin
harloff darn it I got to do it again I
got a pull I got a pull from not just
the movies here I got to go through
Clone Wars and I got to go through
rebels and I have to go through the
novels that I gotta say it's target
Tarkin is is ruthless Tarkin is
intelligent Tarkin is second to the
Emperor as one of the best villains of
all time start there you go I hear what
you're talking about Ken nap sock I hate
to sound like Captain cannon over here
but I got to go to the books and James
will she knows writing of Tarkin in both
the book Tarkin and now catalyst adds a
layer to Tarkin he's not just Peter
Cushing and slippers to me anymore he's
a man holding the Empire's leash not
just Vader's I'm going Tarkin Veda
release him as you wish
that is to Fort arc and he wins it right
off the bat Michael would you have
anything else to say I mean I was
definitely leaning Tarkin that said I do
really love Jabba Jabba was great torque
was it in there job of what I got my
vote
grand moff tarkin moving on we have two
divisions left
first up the sidekick division c-3po
r2d2 bb-8 wicked salacious be crumb and
Jar Jar Binks how dare you Jar Jar in a
clean sweep
Michael barity my mind is going in so
many different places rolling through
all my logic there it's gonna go to r2d2
boom 1 Oh r2d2 Christian yeah look it's
a two-way race between the old school in
the new school it's between r2d2 and
bb-8 bb-8 very helpful you haven't seen
what he's going to do yet but we have
seen the body of work of r2d2 he's great
he's calm he's cool collected he'll get
smashed to bits and he'll still come
back and help out another day he's great
takes a look and keep on ticking that's
r2d2 moving on can any thoughts
I mean salacious beat crumbs laughs is
worth it
but keep keep in mind this the fact
about r2d2 he kept the secret of who
Luke's family was in the history he kept
it the entire time obi-wan and Bail
Organa everyone trusted that little
didn't wipe his mind they didn't wipe
his mind yeah the guy's a vault all
right r2d2 moving on this is the final
division of this bracket we've worked
our way through eight divisions there's
one more division out there with major
characters in it that you're probably
all thinking about we'll get to that in
just a sec let's keep going through our
bracket so guys I know is super tough to
make those choices but now it gets even
tougher because all of those winners are
facing off against each other can you
believe it let's do this the nerf-herder
division versus the sith division Lando
Calrissian versus Emperor Palpatine
let's start with Ken naps aw man I love
Lando I loved that cape he's so smooth
he's cool and he changed his character
changed but she Palpatine is the force
of evil in the story that galaxy
I gotta go with that thing that's one
vote for Emperor P Michael it's
Palpatine all the way he is so very yes
Chris Jess sweep it is palpable for
Palpatine clean sweep this to you is
getting worse all the time all right
okay let's uh let's see what you have to
say about this one the winner of the
Jedi Master Division versus the winner
of the rebellion division Mon Mothma
from rebellion versus obi-wan Kenobi
Christian poor Mon Mothma that's just
the face obi-wan in the second round
here I mean it's ogen one there's just
so much more to what he means the
overall story of Star Wars so yeah it's
open one certainly can perfect world
these two would have dated and fall in
love Hey but right now hope you want to
get a defeat her Mon Mothma is great
she's powerful she's important but
obi-wan is one of the central characters
to the story Michael any other thoughts
it's a sweep there you go
obi-wan moving on I have the high ground
all right
the force Division versus the monster
division ray versus the rank or another
sweep Michael that's a battle I'd love
to see first of all but it's definitely
right yeah yeah that's right ray
gratefully the ring ray
moving on you know what we said it was
gonna be super hard this isn't easy once
we weeded them out now it's clear yeah
mushrooms um yeah some great characters
to choose from here the scum and
villainy division versus the sidekick
division grand moff tarkin versus r2d2
this is a tougher one let's start with
you Christians is a tougher one for sure
I'm gonna say r2d2 r2d2 over talking
even because arch is still running
around talking got blown up all right
that's one for the trash can can the
imprint of Tarkin the Tarkin doctrine
what it meant what he'd helped do in a
bad way when the Republic became the
Empire marking town tarkintown I'm going
with Tarkin boom we're all tied up at
one one you have the most important job
in the galaxy Michael Aaron's down to
you I know you two have the advantage in
knowing more history around the
character of Tarkin so based on purely
my knowledge of the film's I do have to
sway to r2d2 and you can give me a
reading list after this video is done
boom r2d2 moving on let's move on to the
next round Emperor Palpatine versus
obi-wan Kenobi that's a tough one that's
a fair fight yeah Ken talk to us oh man
I mean you got a man I love to quote in
everyday business meetings in Palpatine
everything is proceeding as I have full
I'm still sticking to obi-wan Kenobi
maybe because I want more of him
I want obi-wan in the desert I want to
know about yoga obi-wan why there's so
much to that character obi-wan Kenobi
ma'am that's one for obi-wan Christian
these are two of my favorite characters
and Star Wars Emperor Palpatine without
him you don't get Vader you don't get
the Death Star you don't get the Empire
he constructed everything great that we
know he sent Yoda into hiding he sent
obi-wan into hiding Palpatine Wow
powerful argument Michel barity it all
comes down to you Wow how did you get
this job again don't know the most
crucial job in the galaxy all right wow
it is very true that Palpatine drove
obi-wan into hiding obi-wan ultimately
got the last laugh on Palpatine did he
in the fact that his own apprentice
turned against him
by means of the one that ob1 then pushed
over the edge and trained turned his own
father back yeah but we still don't know
what's going to happen through 7 8 & 9
what imprint he had there there's still
more to come in the legacy of Palpatine
but we're dealing with the right now the
order right now some 7oi if there's a
lot of talk will be hey quo b1 its OB
101 moving on you have failed me all
right whoo we got a great semifinal
matchup brewing but we need one more
competitor gentlemen you got to choose
between Rey and r2d2 Michael barity
we're starting with you while we've seen
a legacy in r2d2 I am very intrigued by
the legacy of Rey and I am going with
Ray for that very reason that's one vote
for Rey I'm pretty sure we're not a
clean sweep here this time I'm going I'm
going with Ray for sure mm-hmm
ken definitely gonna go with ray-ray
damn clean sweeper Rooney what we've got
here is the final matchup of these
divisions we started with eight
divisions we had a winner come out of
each and now we've whittled it down to
the two finalists to determine who will
go into the finals to face someone from
the division we're going to talk about
in just a moment guys it's ray versus
obi-wan Kenobi Kristian harloff ray does
not have the legacy yet that obi-wan has
she's a strong character
I still believe she's developing we're
gonna learn a lot more about her but
there's also room for failure there's
room for it something that happened in
Episode eight and nine where I'm like I
don't know if I like the way she's going
I have seen the established career
already from obi-wan Kenobi he was one
of the best things in the prequels and
certainly one of the best things in the
original trilogy obi-wan Kenobi that's
one vote for obi-wan can nap sock I know
we can't base a lot on the future but I
will based on something that obi-wan
said to Rey in force awakens Rey these
are your first steps
she's got Obi Wan's vote she's got mine
I'm going ray ah boom we are tied up
Michael you have the most important job
check out gotta stop doing this to me
both are convincing arguments I I do
however side more with Christian on the
fact of long-standing legacy and we
don't know yet where ray is going to
fully land I gotta give it to obi-wan I
gotta
well gentlemen obi-wan Kenobi has struck
down all of the other characters to
become more powerful than you could
possibly imagine
but he is not our overall winner yet
because he must face whoever comes out
of the all-star division oh yeah we
weren't going to leave these guys off
the list
relax cool your jets erase that mean
comment that you were gonna write let's
hear who you have to choose from in the
all-star division Han Solo Luke
Skywalker Leia Organa Darth Vader a real
Tuffy Michael let's start with you I
think because the overall Star Wars saga
until 7 and truthfully carrying into 7
is the fall and redemption of Darth
Vader I'm going Darth Vader that's one
vote Darth Vader let's go to Ken she was
an orphan adopted raised by another
family and she winded that family's
politics she helped establish the
rebellion when her planet was destroyed
it was Luke that needed a blanket and
comfort she fought on she was on the
frontlines in Empire she was one of the
key characters in Jedi then she helped
reform the galaxy and as you read on she
is the reason the only person standing
strong against the first order she is
general Leia Organa she is to me the
best Star Wars character Wow ken goes
with Leia Organa aka Princess Leia aka
general a general Leia adorable
arguments here's the thing is that why
sarcasm is strong why was Luke in a
blanket because he was the one going toe
to toe with Darth Vader ultimately
starting Darth Vader's turn and
beginning that Redemption that became so
strong without Luke he's still running
around causing havoc it's all about Luke
Wow
we are split we have a three-way split
on this between Darth Vader Luke
Skywalker and Princess Leia Han Solo
fell off the bridge he's uh
man soon but we are down to these three
could anyone be swayed Christian I can't
be swayed by a piece for the flu all
right I'll go with a Vader argument
because of this ooh
Luke is gonna factor in eight nine
Luke's definitely factor in a seven but
what happened to Luke between six and
seven he got scared too ran away it's
not true because the shadow of his
father the mistakes of his father
probably haunted them and now the most
powerful enemy emerging in the game of
problem worship no no no with worships
the burnt helmet evader the shadow of
anakin is still over this Gallico me
that is Fabio with Darth Vader but wait
your argument while I convinced you to
go to Vader your argument convinced me
to go to Luke see what our cool yeah but
look uh I I think his argument is very
convincing that it is Luke who turns
Vader so Luke is inherently someone who
has most impact your vote went to Vader
yes but your vote went to Luke and in an
unprecedented turn of events Luke
Skywalker is moving on to the finals
we've seen nothing like it in the
history of these weird bracket shows
that we do
gentlemen this means the final matchup
is set to determine the greatest Star
Wars character of all time and uh yeah
it's a clash of old friends obi-wan
Kenobi versus Luke Skywalker let's start
with Ken apse of course um look I could
make a case for it'll be one but it's
hard to argue that he handed off the
baton to Luke and that Luke is the hero
the galaxy needed BAM that's one vote
for Luke Luke is definitely standing on
the shoulders of giants I do feel that
Luke is the carrying point and
trajectory also carrying us forward into
seven and Beyond so yes I'm going Luke
well we've got a clean sweep Luke
Skywalker was not running away from his
father he was looking for the force
during those times and learning more
about himself his legacy building upon
that and we're about to see more
greatness from Luke Skywalker in Episode
eight so is Luke gentlemen this will be
a day long remembered the day that you
chose Luke Skywalker as the greatest
Star Wars character it's Luke Skywalker
Wow
how about it I think we're gonna still
be arguing in the car hey what do you
think about our choices who's your
favorite Star Wars character of all time
let us know in the comment section below
we want to know I got to thank this
awesome panel
Michael barity Kristian harloff check
them out on collider schmoes know and
Ken Knapp sock good to see you again
buddy and thank you for watching I'm Hal
Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye-bye hey
guys did you know that this end card
works with your phone now I know right
click the boxes below to watch more
screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more